thank you
[Music]
all right we're gonna talk about some
U.S laws that are still in effect but
nobody really knows about it okay cool
okay some of them you can't watch a
donkey in a bathtub yeah it really is
stuff like that yeah good good all right
you can't wash a donkey in a bathroom
buddy yeah yeah so in Alabama you can't
dress as a member of the clergy what's a
clergy like a none a nun priest or Rabbi
oh so like in hot for Halloween you
can't do it it's illegal it's illegal
disrespectful what what's a clergy
what's our clergy you think they did
that because they had impersonators and
[__] yeah probably yeah those are
special favors
in uh that makes sense oh here in
Arizona in Arizona what's up brother
it's a it's illegal to interfere with a
with a claw machine oh come on you know
like that gets like stuffed animals like
you can't just like like when it's stuck
yeah you can't [__] mess with it
apparently yeah you can't do nothing or
else it's uh it's a misdemeanor yeah
whoa or a person's [__] wife dude
don't you start playing with that [__]
you let that [__] be that's an Arizona
that's an Arizona law brother don't get
a shot the [__] damn last week this
one's funny don't you look at that one
oh sorry in Arkansas you can't beep your
horn after 9 p.m when you're next to a
sandwich shop what sandwich shop yeah
what the f it has to be specific that's
a [__] small town ass law dude that's
like one of those like this one sandwich
shop that [__] is right there on the
corner they've been complaining for 30
years and then their [__] Uncle
became the sheriff or some [__] what
happened was it's a goddamn mayor the
mayor [__] was an [__] who's just
like I don't want people beeping when I
eat a sandwich make it alone and then
that's what happens when you become a
[__] mayor you're a weirdo dude or
maybe he lived next to the sandwich shop
and he heard people going how the [__]
would I find a sandwich
a lot of traffic by the sandwich shop
and he's like I got a loophole we'll
make it about the sandwich shop he's
probably when he was a worker and he was
in high school and he's like I'm tired
of this [__] when I'm a mayor nobody's
gonna beep a sandwich shop so more it
makes so much sense when you say it like
that oh here's a weird Cali one uh you
can't eat frogs that died during a frog
jumping competition how
this is ridiculous what's a frog jumping
competition this is Mad Lib is it like
at the bar where you like race frogs and
[__]
who's doing that hey you know what if
you have a frog jumping competition new
law you go to jail
hey if you're [__] catching frogs to
make them jump you you're going to jail
my guy you can't own property because it
not only says that but like if I guess
when they had this when the frog dies or
if the frog dies in the competition you
have to destroy the remains eat it let
me say something right now dude if
you're eating frogs
after they die from a competition you're
not allowed to vote Mike
please do not vote you make me nervous
dude why would they just throw the Frog
it's probably all of our aunties and
[__] yeah yeah logic but maybe it has
something to do with maybe they do
something to the Frog to make him win
the like they dope the Frog up and if
you eat it then maybe you could oh [__]
epic abilities I don't know that's what
I was thinking I was thinking maybe they
did something to the Frog I don't know
dude tell us the Frog reason why yeah
I'm gonna go YouTube [__] frog
jumping competitions it's an old it's an
old thing yeah so in Colorado if you
have like a couch that's made for the
indoors where it's upholstered with
fabric you're not allowed to use it
outside yeah because the mold and it's
disgusting yeah God thanks for that yeah
dude for sure I thought it's because
trashy people like to pull it out on the
front porch and then hang out yeah yeah
it's like a low-class looking thing
my neighborhood you ever drive to
Bakersfield
they Park everything on the lawn too
yeah
Delaware parking space Oh Delaware this
one's interesting you can't whisper or
it costs around a place of worship you
can't whisper that makes more sense if
you're Whispering you might be cussing
oh that makes more sense than anything
else that makes the most sense yeah
whisper doesn't make sense to me but
cuss does yeah maybe you Whispering at
church you don't want to be all loud and
[__] no talking at all here's a Hawaii
one that you might find interesting so
in Hawaii you can't post a billboard
that's advertising something that isn't
being sold on the same property the
Billboard's sitting on that's weird what
also if you want a McDonald's billboard
has to be on a McDonald's so if you want
like a strip club billboard the strip
club better be on the same property as
well wow very reasonable
so you don't want to be like Costco
three miles that way yeah exactly
exactly it has to be where it is yeah I
don't think they allow it very much
that's the reason why yeah it might be
the reason yeah beautiful views no
[__] Billboards yeah yeah yeah that's
Hawaii
how about this Illinois one you're not
allowed to dye a baby chick
huh like oh like die like change the
color oh yeah because they'll dye them
too yellow now they'll do that [__] for
gender reveals yeah that's why they'll
dive them too yellow and then they'll
sell them as a healthy chick and it's
like no no I want to know what color
that chick is oh okay baby
baby get snappy snappy [__] I run
barbell marketing okay come on come on
I can't in Indiana you're not allowed to
uh catch a fish with your bare hands
what good because you know why the
[__] you ever see those guys that
catfish guys yeah the catfish guys
sometimes they lose a hand it's for
their own safety starving though wait
wait wait yeah sometimes they lose a
hand did I just make that up Anthony no
I'm asking you for a little Clarity dick
none hey man you ever watch those
catfish guys so they go like this and
they stick in the little holes in the
river and the cat is going oh food
yeah you're an eagle scout I feel like
you know how to do with their hand yeah
if it's an alligator it's called a
catfishing God okay see in my mind the
way that you worded that I'm like a
catfish is biting a handoff that doesn't
make sense we stick it in the wrong hole
[__] different things sometimes
exactly yeah dude can you always be the
guy that agrees to these laws I'm
already doing it okay cool I like the uh
set you up literally how about this in
Kansas you're not allowed to play on a
children's playground if you're over 14.
yeah absolutely oh yeah but yeah but
what if it's like after 9 p.m and
there's no kids oh kids shouldn't be
playing after 9pm on that same place
[__] used to finger banging
playgrounds I could tell you have a
finger banging face three bars dude yeah
you know what as a dad behind us I want
that everywhere baby yeah yeah cause my
um I bring the kid to the park because
I'm tired go play right I say go play
and he goes Papa can you play with me
I'm like I can't I'm over 14. you have
to go play by yourself thank you
if you're over if you're over 14 and you
want to play at a playground
gotta get more friends dude
you can't be kicking it with these
little kids unless you're like maybe
babysitting but then you use that excuse
of like yeah people that want to be big
brothers are sus yeah get out of here
dude I never got that yeah man that's
their actual big brothers
well that's that's even more weird we
need legal documentation no but when you
guys just joins like I want to be a big
brother to some kid I'm like why dog
yeah
dude yeah yeah guys that want to work
with kids too like two like they're too
enthusiastic you're like I did What's
your deal yeah because real big brothers
are trying to shake their little
brothers away exactly [__] and your
mom's like take them to the mall with
you oh [__] that [__] yeah [__] that guy
that guy's queer
this is the 90s come on guys this is the
90s yeah 90s all right what about this
in Maryland in Maryland it is illegal to
manufacture or sell stink bombs and
where in Maryland why who won I don't
know they were so much fun
those little glass things
yeah they did smell like [__] yeah why
is that good well maybe in Maryland it
was an epidemic maybe kids were getting
a little too crazy with it too stinky
and they were the epicenter yeah they're
the epicenter of production from ice
cream trucks and then you crack it and
it's glass yeah yeah dude we were just
talking about that like 10 seconds this
guy just woke up from asleep
dude
I was at the mall in my head yeah
he was you're still in way you're still
in Westfield he's like oh [__] orange
juice I was all right here here's a good
one I'm trying to ditch my little
brother Massachusetts yeah if you play
the national anthem
not in its entirety it is absolutely
illegal yeah you should play the whole
[__] thing because what are you in a
real American well what if you're
learning how to play it and then you
can't [__] finish it are you American
or not practicing your own home don't go
in public what happens if you don't play
the whole thing you go to James this is
America we finished when we started so
big brother 1770 except Vietnam but that
don't [__] matter all right dude
we're gonna talk about it we don't talk
about damn right because nothing else
needs to be said at all all right how
about this Mississippi it's you get
fined 100 bucks for swearing
yeah because they're they're sweet so
they're gentlemen and and ladies there
how should a Mississippi man speak
how does a gentleman of Mississippi how
would a gentleman of Mississippi greet a
lady Madam yeah hello my lady
uh easy max
they're supposed to be brave teasers you
say stuff like that slang you don't say
that to a lady what's a city in
Mississippi like that Mississauga kick
your ass Billy you let me know if you
want me to take this brother out all
right in Missouri you can't sell a car
on Sunday
you know in Nevada or in Vegas uh car
dealerships aren't open on Sundays yeah
see is that a rule even Marty bird
doesn't sound okay
porn there's no porn on Sunday oh you're
gonna love this Nebraska one you can't
marry someone while having an STD yeah
that's Unholy do you get a checkup
before you get married that's my rule
too dude I think that's a good one
actually what if it's uh the SUV you
gave them
right now
right now you finish what you said dude
what's up what about Texas have you ever
married
have you ever been the ordained minister
to anybody no I haven't okay why I'm
just curious I like that one though yeah
that one's pretty cool dude I probably
had like a syphilis outbreak good one
because I think that one also I think
the real application of that is like
let's say surprise a couple gets married
if if the couple gave the other person
an STD then that marriage is null ah ah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
people that have herpes and like get
married dude whoa I don't know the
origin of this but it's crazy though
I've heard anyways in New Mexico
guess what you can't do what in New
Mexico you can't wear a sombrero while
dancing
they probably wanted to kick out the
Mexicans out of the club it's called
being in a [__] Trump rally Dude
Perfect
trust me don't do it it's not worth it
you guys ever been a trump rally there's
a lot of dancing no I've I've
coordinated them coordinated I've never
attended them someday always the
bridesmaid for some reason I feel like
there's some kind of cowboy hats in line
dancing involved yeah oh yeah they're
saturated in the market dude yeah
thank you
foreign